today joined by the ukrainian ambassador
to the united kingdom fadin pristiko who
has also previously served as ukraine's
foreign minister hello to you thank you
for joining us on the program mr
ambassador uh it's a pleasure to have
you here how concerned are you about
what's happening on the border quite
concerned all these hundred thousand
people is a serious danger it's not
enough to topple down our military but
that's serious danger for
next you know stage of aggression
what do you expect to happen
we hope that this negotiations will ease
the situation somehow
i agree with the command that's probably
the russians are trying to you know to
take to find the lever in negotiations
with the united states about the
you know stance in europe the rockets
the forces
unfortunately they're taking the
ukrainians protests and that's what
we've been living through for seven
years we now started you know to get
accustomed to this constant status of
war and i hope that this negotiations
and the next in nato then the noise he
will allow to sort of
ease the tension
to what extent though is its saber
rattling uh by the russian leader that's
what i also hope because the language
they use derogative language you know
nato should pack up belongings and get
to 1997 somewhere and then today's
reaction that's the first stage was
astonishingly well went this is
something where i feel the lots lots of
emotions and hopefully this emotion is
just to raise the stakes and you know
push through the initiations
the west is very much focused on what's
happening with china at the moment is
this not as some might suggest just an
attempt by the russian leader to try to
remain relevant
he's becoming relevant and more and more
in this area of the former soviet union
look at the kazakhstan what's going on
there belarus is already taken by
russians
ukraine is more or less the last piece
he needs so now on the map so he's he's
he's pushing and i'm not sure how
western leaders are prepared to push as
hard as the russians do well nato has
said they won't
we'll see what nato will do at least
couple of days ago they settled down the
position they the common positions for
themselves these negotiations that next
months will allow to see where the the
the parties
really stay
i i i heard you um speaking about the
situation a couple of days ago quite
inflammatory language saying that we are
potentially heading towards another
world war is that is that really the
case you know when when the russians
started in crimea seven years ago
leaders asked us not to do anything not
to start this third war now we see that
we lost 10 000 people over these 70
years seven percent of our territory is
gone the crimea two million people
peninsula is taken by russians so you
know when we are hearing this language
that let us stay calm let us think yes
we are all calm and restrained but
russians are doing what they are doing
so we have some someday we have to draw
the line and tell them you know guys
that's the line the threat whatever you
call it but we we are not fighting in
this part of the globe in 21st century
and what is that line
i believe the russians had had to go
home that's what they offered nato pack
up their things and get home and what
will make them go home that's a good
question i believe that economic
situation in russia is not the best it's
not the the wealthiest nation in the
world
the economic sanctions are already in
place aren't they from from europe maybe
they're not enough if they don't feel
maybe not that what you're asking for
i'm asking for this we're also asking
for the weapons because we have right to
defend ourselves and some nations were
very reluctant to provide us with
um as far as um president putin is
concerned we heard him speaking last
week and he was saying actually
nato did promise that they wouldn't move
another inch further to the west to the
east of germany back in in 1990 when we
saw the collapse of the soviet union
and he says that that
promise should be honored first of all
this is urban legend even mikhail
who was negotiation at the time was
mentioned that there was no such a
promise and by the way we've been
promised by russia the sentiment that
was there was such a thing maybe i don't
remember that i was 21 years old at that
time i don't remember any sentiment and
nato didn't promise anything but i do
remember that when we gave up the
weapons nuclear weapons we've been
promised by russia united kingdom united
states that will be defended and that's
where we are right now
where are you as far as um cyber attacks
are concerned we know that that russia
is pretty effective at those they're
always bombarding us especially foreign
affairs and then the critical
infrastructure with the cyber attacks
that's the matter actually the life
we're living in we're trying to you know
to gain more and more experience than
that with the assistance of of nations
or the west of the nato but that's
that's normal life unfortunately for
ukrainians and what form are those cyber
attacks taking is it against your health
services against your banks what
sometimes the against the diplomatic
service and our correspondence sometimes
again the critical infrastructure like
energy we've been through a couple of
decades because of the infrastructure
being interrupted by that
um what would you say to the i mean
obviously the talks are going
um in geneva at the moment but what do
you want them
presumably particularly the americans
and and and europe more generally what
what do you want them to do
thank you that's a very good question
what we what we fear the most that's a
call big deal when behind our backs
something will be baked and the ukraine
will be just the price for the russians
to step down
this is something we don't want and this
is something we'd like to warn our
friends and partners in the west if you
reach some agreement like that we won't
just we won't budge
so you're asking for more economic
sanctions even more economic sanctions
although that is what punishes the uh
russian people rather than the russian
leadership if i have a choice i would
ask
to help ukraine than than inherit
russians and that is in the future yes
there's economic and economic uh help
that's troops that support and by the
way that's the nato future for ukraine
what do you think russia wants out of um
all of this russia is trying to show
that they want to have a respect in
international communities they return
back as a second pillar whatever they
have
more importantly i believe that
this year is hundredth year of creation
of soviet union unfortunately in putin's
mind there is something you know to
celebrate in our case that's what the
that's what we're trying to escape from
he's he's an older man he can't go on
forever um
do you think well i don't know i don't
know um do you feel that potentially
uh the west and and maybe even ukraine
gives him too much respect
i believe the ukrainians definitely did
not now and look at the nazarbayev last
last leader of the same of the same
sword he was 19 years in power almost
like putin and now all the troubles in
kazakhstan this is kazakhstan's very
close to russia a mineral rich country
with the very little of the freedoms so
that's the future he has to look at not
ukraine not the west but that's internal
problems he might face very soon those
hundred thousand troops are camped on
your border as we speak if they start to
move across the border what do you see
the next move be
so many dead bodies will be returned
back to moscow and kiev that's for sure
and whether he will use the the full the
extent of his might or it's just very
limited to show us and west that we have
to get back to the table of negotiations
but we're already at the table he
doesn't have to move if he moves we will
be fighting
he is not in a but russia is not in a
position to be able to hold those
hundred thousand troops in ukraine for
very long though is he
they have this troop somewhere so they
can they can keep them even close to
ukrainian borders and you know when when
he has an idea where to spend his money
he would rather spend for the military
than for his own people so he can keep
them at for some time and it's not the
the biggest number they had in may they
have 135 000 people
the ukraine is not in a position to be
able to you say that you will be sending
um russian soldiers back home in body
bags again you're not in a position as a
country to be able to continue on with
that level of force for very long unless
you turn to your big brothers
in nato and the rest of europe for
support
that's what we're doing unfortunately we
are not in one of those uh family asking
for the help we just can back nato and
and the europeans to help us to get
somehow this situation
how critical are the talks today and and
for the rest of the week in geneva i
believe that this time when we are
talking still are relatively low risk at
least a week i mean we have this osce
nato and this bilateral negotiations
after week we will see what will happen
what do you mean by that
i mean anything can happen we've been
through it you know for many people here
in some science thinkable to have war
that's what's unthinkable for us seven
years ago now we're losing soldiers more
or less each and every day and i'm sure
that your countrymen are looking towards
kazakhstan and seeing what's happening
there
um can they take any lessons from that
i believe that kazakhstan is losing the
statehood something happened to belarus
before that's what ukrainians were
wearing in all these nations that guys
if you wanted to be as ourselves to
wanted to be independent you have to
rule better you have to find some way to
you know rotate your garments which we
did not not perfectly but at least we
are somewhere there because this way or
you're ruling your country is not
sustainable and what would you say to
the british government this morning
finally
i see that your government is
understanding what is happening and i
know that some visits to to the region
are planning right now so the people
here at least in this capital understand
actually what happened with russia and
around russia okay mr ambassador it's a
pleasure to talk to you thank you very
much indeed for joining us we do
appreciate it